[Music]
people issues are fundamental to
competitive advantage that's exactly
what this program is all about the
intersection of talent management
culture and performance people is a
vehicle for you to become not just
bigger but better by being more
innovative more efficient and then
thinking of how can your people
management processes help you shape
culture so that you can achieve
performance this program can shift your
entire mindset about the way that you
lead in the people space and help you
transition from a traditional HR model
and people strategy to something very
cutting-edge we'll present research on
not just startups but much more
importantly scale ups in Silicon Valley
and in particular their talent models
and what is it we can learn from them
learning from the Silicon Valley best
practices is obviously not a bad place
to start if you're looking to recruit
good talent to be here in Silicon Valley
learn from all kinds of innovative
talented people is incredibly inspiring
and I think you walk away with some
really concrete tools and frameworks
that you can apply in your organization
right away this program really is meant
for people who are keen to question
their own playbook for talent management
think of it as a gym where you can
actually build new muscles work on new
parts of your organization so that when
you go back you actually have an agenda
of things that you want to subtract from
your organization and also add to
your organization's tools that you can
begin to use when you go back to work
the mix of theory and practice gives me
the best ideas and tips to take home
with the ideal participants or HR
leaders from large established companies
seeking to redesign their talent
playbook and business executives heading
product groups strategic business units
and even corporations who can actually
initiate change the blend of
international people the one that attend
here alongside world-class speakers that
says this cost quite apart from the rest
the diversity of the class being able to
engage in dialogue about people strategy
with individuals who come here from all
over the world and have different roles
and perspectives it's really really
fascinating it's a set of frameworks
it's a set of social science based tools
it's a set of corporate experiences that
actually provision you to develop your
own agenda if anybody considering taking
this course do it it's a life changing
experience something you'll never forget
you
[Music]